[Musique]
ok les gars on arrivé devant la porte et
man yann ce qui nous attend on va
décharger les cartons et on est beaucoup
risque car toile à jan aps la justice et
u15 genou faire pas là c'est à cause du
créneau que j'ai fait une gratte et mon
permis c'est même pas un créneau ça veut
dire quoi ici a pas vu comment ces
jours-ci viande car là bien aux gars là
un bon onze gars là
[Musique]
ça fait
la vaisselle
bourhis boris maurice je vais plaider
non tel rien du tout car le camion tu
touches à rien
t'es pas obligé de t'énerver comme ça
aux nôtres eros et commence à beaucoup
et ça fait plaisir de tous un
téléphone je monte je redescends c'est
bon
je peux pas si tu mets le lait avant les
chocolats ces morts entre où nous
relient gaza y est c'est le grand jour
le nouvel apport pour elle découvrira
son incroyable jusqu'au week-end ça va
ça se passe
le micro ondes ça se démonte pas ça se
porte comme ça c'est plus facile donc je
suis mort sauf une en confiant à cannes
jeunesse le décrocher
[Musique]
allo jorrand franchement tu es un bon ça
fait plaisir d'avoir des amis quand des
amis gay est en vient on fait une pause
ou quoi à quel poste a fait 2 kg de la
famille là c'est trop j'ai une idée au
pire souffrent les livres encore un
comme ça un parent beaucoup plus vite
attends je n'avais jamais lu ce que je
suis à avoir peur mais je veux juste lui
d'avant en fait mais le dernier était
peut être même chose dans le livre mais
elle mois à ronger les cartons times je
l'avais vu les écoles pourquoi balancer
ça peut lui tout seul
il est vraiment trop lent le podcast
c'est vrai se dérangent parfois notre
quel paquet puis pause 6 4
je pose mes bijoux
c'est pas tout ça là bas marc vella toi
moi je vends j'habite ici vous faites
quoi chez moi chez toi oui chez toi oui
chez moi à bord 17 bâtiments ben ouais
c'est chez toi c'est chez moi même
bâtiment b sera en face d'accord si
c'est le bâtiment c on est motivés
ils apprennent ton pas de là haut
j'écoute un podcast ci eeckhout an post
pour cause est agressif avec à séoul à
aller vous êtes sûr c'est pas chez moi
non c'est pas chez toi kraft mon frère
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui fait pour apple le
conseiller facile à l'eau
je me suis trompé bâtiment il ya toutes
mes affaires dehors et à 4-4 démonter ma
fenêtre ces bandits et bien sûr
l'application check vous avez des
réductions pour faire un bel à des
déménageurs professionnels
franchement je vous kiffe
merci franchement merci les gars vous
êtes incroyables mais vous êtes dans le
top 3 2 mais des ménagères préférées
allez ciao même temps de déménager en
sont ils pas beaucoup connu que le
encore la poste a vomi est la fin avec
la classe tournée en asie - tiens je
peux prendre avec toi
moi si je dois bouger la gentillesse
était lavé les mains non non pas encore
je me lave les mois déjà et vos dettes
vas-y ont surgi 15 cents
pour le principal c'est que il ya toutes
les affaires donc on fait une visite
on vous dit
oui je vous appelle parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'électricité dans la porsche 3
attendez je garde ouais non votre
contrat bien active et non en tout et on
fait fonctionner correctement des allume
ya pas de lumière j'étais certain que je
faisais pas de nos poules à bail par
découle en fait
c'est quoi si s'est épuisée last chaos
donc on peut s'appeler devant un
bon du tout le monde garde le nouvel
appart
[Musique]